my book is called ready player one and
it's a novel set about 35 years in the
future and it's about an eccentric Willy
wonka-esque video game designer who
leaves his fortune and control of his
company to ever consult these video game
puzzles that he's left left behind and
they all have to deal with his passions
which are 1980s pop culture and classic
video games and John Hughes movies and
the book is about these kids in the
future who spent all this time studying
80s pop culture so that they can unlock
these riddles and win this massive
fortune there's an easter egg hidden in
the book it's not hidden in the e-book
but it's hidden in the print editions of
the book both the hardcover and the soft
cover and if you can find this hidden
website address in the book it leads you
to the first of three increasingly
difficult videogame challenges and the
first person to complete all three of
these will win this car
this is a 1981 DeLorean the engine is in
the back trunk is in the front so you
can keep your your luggage into
plutonium and whatever else you need up
there I have added a screen accurate
flux capacitor that is flexing right now
and also has a hoverboard and I will
throw in a Huey Lewis CD with the stereo
so you're all you're all set
it's the only car I know we're just
people giving you thumbs up and honking
their horn and freaking out wherever you
drive it so it's so much fun so far I've
driven it from Austin Texas all the way
up to Seattle Washington and then down
here to San Francisco and it handles
like a dream and I've been driving at 88
miles per hour the entire time
trying to get a speeding ticket at that
speed but I haven't able to do it yet
I'm so I'm stole my quests for an 88
mile-per-hour speeding ticket